Oh
good afternoon everyone my name is
Shamika Sharma and I will be your
moderator today
thank you for taking time to join us in
this webinar redefining playscapes for
all the session today is brought to you
by y2 and it's supported by design
Singapore Council the National Agency
for design in Singapore and the National
Design Centre the webinar is part of the
national design centres program lineup
with a thematic focus on power play
weiter is honored to be invited to
contribute to this discourse exploring
how the concept of play and design helps
to elevate user experience and
differentiate the business from another
information on other programs in this
month's lineup will be shared with you
at the end of the session allow me to
quickly introduce myself I'm a UK
registered architect and principal of my
eponymous multidisciplinary design
studio in Singapore built on over 15
years experience in architecture on four
continents in recent years I've had the
opportunity to exhibit interactive
concrete sculptures for rest and play in
the context of my favorite play scape
the beach at sculpture by the sea in
Australia when I was first invited to
water a to talk about playscapes
I immediately thought of architect I'll
do my next playgrounds as well as of
course his orphanage in the Netherlands
but I really considered play through
composition with an emphasis on pure
geometry while the target audience while
the target audience of Vinayak's
playgrounds was indeed children play
sticks to find themselves separately
from playgrounds because of their
multi-generational appeal
the foreplay escapes that will be
presented today are immediately striking
for the way plays expressed her color
geometry composition and piece of
texture of course play needs to be
experienced the fourth dimension is
essential I hope that many of you have
the opportunity to visit some of these
plays
you
before we proceed with the presentations
I would like to highlight a few
housekeeping notes should you encounter
any technical issues please reach out to
our technical team through the chat soon
chat function we ask for your patience
and understanding should conditions be
less than perfect during this webinar
your audio will be on mute mode however
we welcome questions throughout the
session please keep your questions
coming in through the zum-zum Q&A
function when posting a question please
identify yourself and indicate if you'd
like a specific panelist to address your
question
with that out of the way please allow me
to introduce the speakers for this
evening
yawn : managing director of y2 who will
be speaking on dreamscapes between play
and art young fellah is the co-founder
of y2 singapore in paris with the rich
with the fundamental belief that design
must serve a cause he is built a rich
multicultural experience from his
formative years in Indonesia France
and Singapore embracing
multidisciplinary approaches to grow the
Singapore practice Yan has established
diverse expertise in sustainable
architecture cultural curation and
exhibition design in his talk titled
dreamscapes between play and art Yan
will be sharing how dreams can take you
to wondrous places they motivate you to
find and express yourself and give you
the courage to become greater committed
to inspire young and curious minds
through art multi-dimensional playful
and interactive art works and to spark
curiosity for the young ones about the
world around them encourage openness to
discover diversity and imagine new
possibilities a journey that leaves play
and art next up we'll have architect low
jump a senior architect at our SP who
will be speaking on a retail play space
launch of thing is a senior architect at
RSP his first experience with the joys
of space making and world crafting come
from his love of video games steeped in
folklore and magic as well as comic
books he believes that architecture and
design are exercises and empathy he was
one of the lead architects involved in
the latest redevelopment of food on
Singapore when not attending to matters
of the built environment shooting can be
found exploring dungeons and killing
dragons in the world of warcraft in his
talk titled a retail play space he will
share more about the recently completed
food on as a retail space designed to
cater to a new generation of consumers
looking for a different engagement
experience we will take a look at how
basic concepts of play and make-believe
can shape this reimagine retail
experience
bullying that will have Leonard o studio
director of Singapore in Beijing a
trombone studio drives I tell who will
be speaking on the squirrel in you let
her join Rumble studio dry settle in
2008 where he's the studio director of
Samper in Beijing his academic
background and design and translate the
juncture between humans of their
environment with the aim of finding a
long-term sustainable balance between
them
his approach involves extensive
collaboration with diverse professions
to foment holistic landscape based
solutions that engage in educate users
while respecting the environment in his
top titled the squirreling you Leonard
will share the importance of
contextualizing adventure play and how
nature can inspire playground design an
example through the lens of the largest
public adventure playground dancing in
Singapore in Jurong lakeside gardens and
finally we will have thaliana Surya
Renata and Florian
heinzelmann founders of Chou architects
from Indonesia they will be speaking on
5 P public-private partnership plate
places Chou is an award-winning
architectural and urban design practice
bonded by the architect couple taliano
Surya Renata Florian heinzelmann and
Tobias Hoffman in the Netherlands
Germany and then later in Indonesia Shah
is best known for their micro libraries
which merged community and environmental
design aspects with material
experimentation into novel
multifunctional technologies they
further realized several public space
projects but also residential projects
for public as well as private clients
Sean's multinational background and
international experience and design
practices enables them to come up with
their unique design approach in their
talk titled 5 P private public
partnership playplace da Liana and
Florian will share their recent works on
public spaces realizing that homo
Luden's isn't everyone of us young and
old rich or poor inserting loose ludic
spaces here and there should be on an
architect's agenda what play spaces are
possible when facing budget restrictions
and many other challenges there are many
factors stakeholders commitment funding
availability climatic consideration
community engagement user readiness and
perhaps political will and the
Indonesian context brings possibilities
as well as complexity into the design
process execution and usage I will now
hand you over to our first speaker Yong
hi everyone - thank you thank you very
much I make up what is great our
introduction and thank everyone for
being here so it's a pleasure to be here
with you and to share one of these ideas
on on redefining place I will be sharing
my screen so here it is all right so I
hope you can wanna see my my screen so
dreams games between play and art so and
yeah me too and so we were sharing that
today so I first of all let's just
remind ourself like how did this idea of
museum come about so it is as ancient as
the ancient Greek ancient Greece like
this where basically the museum was a
temple dedicated to the music inspiring
for art science and literature
fast forward modern modern days also
dedicated to interactive thought and
creativity so when we move throughout
the modern days in early beginnings
where we have this first genre while at
the composition amateur the very first
modern museum and basically collect all
of the medicinal plant and later on
century later the opening up the
menagerie where basically it was touring
the right for now but also at the time
cabinets of curiosity as we can see on
that on that Hume where it was
displaying a collection of artifact
classical and ancient art as you can see
you again here so since then museum
development has been prolific all around
the world some of the most iconic museum
as you as you know for example the
National Gallery in the UK the Med mr.
tose or even our own National Gallery
single major big museum renown
renowned internationally so within these
we have a certain way of displaying
heart very conventional way former
museum visual display will mount ceiling
mount showcase floor mount all of these
are very common
we use very used to that so again we can
see that the National Gallery a very
classical way I designed it so I know
exactly how it is so very classical
corresponding to international standard
but most of the time what we have is
this is I don't touch don't run don't
run
total clap don't sing on draw more to
happen sometimes a museum unknown is
actually associated to dream like play
scape so what can we do about that can
use them be machines to dream at a
crossroad between art and play so that
that's what I would like to share with
you too they can museum the machines to
dream at the crossroad between art and
play of course yes I'm asking you the
question is because it is yes and and
again I will go back to the National
Gallery because there is an amazing team
there in the National Gallery that is
pushing for many things to reconfigure
yourself so to achieve these together we
shall focus on the body in space and how
it perceives and how it interacts we
need also the body in space
Myrtle's and solar strategies the five
senses combined with physical ergonomics
the sound light temperature and even
cognitive abilities how do we how do we
react to it how our physical brain is is
welcoming a part of this like things
that are surrounding us that are
exciting us so there is the two project
that I would like to share with you that
are very close to my heart because it is
something that we developed again with
the fantastic team at the National
Gallery for the two antenna steamers
warming dreamers and together we've been
pushing the boundary of of the museum to
develop something different from new
experiences the cover that we did three
years ago was around the work of the UN
and even who has now passed where he's a
very important figure
an out figure in Singapore very well
known for his color the movement that
surely the passageway domain basically
so I had a great chance of working with
him and with my team and also because
national gallery to develop an entire
experience for for the kids so talking
to him we understood that basically is
where the characteristic of his working
this combination between reality and
dream so together what is basically what
can we offer to the audience so in this
regard is inspire because she was a
performing artist we can be getting
inspired we looked at the work of
Kandinsky for example I don't have been
to to see the movement of the body lines
and how we can deconstruct that and our
design aims were to capture this
harmonious contrast between dreams and
reality representing other the themes
his work of color shown and movement so
with this we say to look at body
movement body posture and how we can
invite the kids and the visitors to
perhaps we create those body movement
the form the dreamer all of us and the
yellow man of course we went to the
dreamer and Needleman the form in the
shade so what we create when we move so
we create shapes with our with our body
and so all together the dreamer in the
dream that are happening in the space so
with this we develop some activities
with the National Gallery team and to
have away this combination between small
and big when we are small when you're
killed how do we perceive bleeding's and
vice-versa so that was the start of the
journey and then we develop all of those
little characters to to have the kids by
seeing them said well I can do the same
and so to take part in to start to
express yourself the expression of your
body is one of the first form of art so
with this design a Tamiya trimmer from
Lilly well then we said to incorporated
personas inside the space and here I
even witnessed once I was there and you
have a girl she was doing exactly the
same so it was exactly what we wanted to
do to invite the kids to go in it to
rent to German to go in between all of
those codes like that and indeed to
selection being and running and climbing
because it is like a sort of like form
of art by expressing your body in the
space and then with this like we
continued to invite the young one to
discover to touch to fear to see the
wind happening inside and since you
wanted to excite the five senses we even
asked them to create sounds well not
everyone had enjoyed that because just
super super loud but it was a kind of
like very fine Orchestra done by the
kids to basically like she'd some night
life daily life kind of things and even
twine like this my little girl like she
exactly understood what to do just I
check inside it and just Angus so again
you said you're spillin a small and big
what is small forest was gigantic for
her so also very very exciting to see
that and to run the tour and again and
again okay kids never stop so it was to
really develop all of that for them and
not to forget to dream and sometimes I'm
pointing into pose to sit down to
another body posture to enter in the in
this kind of environment where you can
write your dreams and your fear and you
can just like place them on those wings
angel bird that you can put on that kind
of cage so we chose the moment of dream
as well so following the success of
these small big dreamers we we had the
great opportunity to continue the
journey with the National Gallery and to
develop this experience see that
embarrass even memorable for meaningful
learning outcomes and I already member
the team they are always sending us what
is the learning outcome what I want to
keep we between them to always make them
croaking so so that's that's why with
the Bloodless immersive and memorable
experiences embracing wonders it was
last year the turns be entirely again at
the National Gallery so how that the
setting was a bit different where we
were working with different artists and
so the artists they were having the
artwork such as equally amazing autism
internet star memories on a Firefly so
she's women for the center and for all
of his artworks and so we could
collaborate with him to give even more
life to them to have more interaction I
know that nowadays is a bit more
difficult with 19 but how can we trigger
emotions notion of like diversity
togetherness respect caring for each
other love so those interactive moment
where kids could die jumping going
somewhere around the length of going
inside together and by doing that it was
triggering some light triggering some
sound so from the artwork of echo we
could do something even more interactive
and we even did that gigantic lantern
that was not moving for the kiss convoy
in ourselves we were the thing - making
this very big light sound which was like
electrifying a lot of kids were so
excited to go inside
also we worked with 12 artists every
Canadian time who who did his current
window switch from us would connect
everything and so we could develop an
entire like play scape and that's what
we started to do here to sketch to
define some zones of like different
activities and to discover at any point
of time different world because again
like
down at the height of the kids that kind
of fruit myself gigantic for them so so
here we were exhibiting some of possible
kind of mini mother for the kids to
enjoy school on their pollen so it was
to trigger creativity as well and I
ought to say larger than life kind of
Robert so trust me this one eyed people
what was I reading on it wanted to climb
on to take picture and so on so you have
to put a mark of Caesar around to make
sure that you are not jumping on it but
but it is of course inviting and
exciting in at the same time some moment
of break of pose some moment of respite
so the fabric design is dismal eternal a
sofa like that and even to look into the
imagination of floating structure that
we recreated inside the space for kids
also to dream even more and so the
discussed after that I would like to
share with you is from million uncle
from from young man and so like just
this kind of sketch and when we are also
architects well we could design this
like come from house and from the center
of the structure I had to build it and
to insert it into an amazing space
historical lobby of the former Supreme
Court so can you imagine to place there
come from house right inside the
National Gallery right inside the
Congress Supreme Court to invite teams
will go inside to do all of the other
means as well as scratching things and
and so on together in the same space so
to have them more excitement and here
not to forget that the young ones
somehow disabilities so to welcome
everyone to make sure that all kids can
go can go inside you can experience also
the whole sort of experience in no
matter how they are or where they're
coming from so it is something very
welcoming and again I'm I'm thankful to
the National Gallery to to develop that
and to create a different kind of Museum
so
conclusion I would like to me look
forward what is the future of museum the
future of museum is Definity to create
dreamscapes for our modern landscape a
place camp we know how to do it but
dreamscapes is reading the next level
and when we say :
yeah shall we do examples for kids but
actually it was quite funny to see how
the parents were also reacting to that
and independent working with the artist
to see aha we can develop those
installations to welcome everyone so I
hope that you enjoyed this district and
and then for more Q&A at the end of the
sessions thanks again everyone and let's
talk later on this risky dreams cakes
forward thank you thank you very much
young for your fascinating talk about
dreamscapes and I would now like to hand
you over to Joo ping shooping will be
talking about play in retail a retail
play space and I will hand you over to
him now thank you
everyone wait I think my camera is not
working hi hello from the RSP office can
you guys see my screen nope aha
okay oh no the moment for everybody
right hi everyone my name is tripping up
from RSP and today I'm gonna talk about
the retail play space specifically in
relation to the what do we did with when
I'm the redevelopment so before we go to
Fran let me bring you to Azeroth Azeroth
is the world in which the world of
warcraft is created and the world of
warcraft really is an online game with
millions of players it is personally for
me the best MMORPG there is there the
Final Fantasy boys of course won't
disagree but it really is the 2020
iteration of play and once Bay's
concepts are so if we look at the
history of the world of warcraft
actually is based on current
fundamentals of role-playing games which
is set out in Dungeons and Dragons and
we will go through some base concepts of
play in this and see how this was
applied to look for non-law and perhaps
we can project into the future with some
ideas that we have incubating in
Singapore all around the world for
perhaps a future of retail and
experiential design so just a brief
introduction on for now
Fernan is what a space that we call a
live work and play in everywhere in
between
it has a very prosperous GA of 8888
thousand square feet and nla or 325
square square feet so nla is net
leasable area part of the strata of
square officers as well as a hotel with
200 saronite apartments facing the hill
street side the team was huge RSP was
the lead consultant with the developer
of capital land and the rest of the
design consultants are as shown on
screen we also had a contractor which is
a homegrown firm will hop pairing up
with obayashi for joint venture so this
is set some context for the development
finance sits in the Civic district so it
is near icon success
the Supreme Court and Treasuries or
construction was challenging and it's
also flanked by ho Street and North
which roads which are two main
thoroughfares leading to the development
the massing is a strong so what we're
going to be focusing on is the red
portion which is the retail podium and
that is where a lot of the clear
concepts come in they're also brilliant
designs done by farm for the hotel
component which is the blue area as well
as office components where tenants have
taken out large amounts of space for
their own twist on playing and working
in the Civic district so let's talk
about just a retail portion this is a
sectional rendering I was very hard to
find a photo that fully expresses this
on the actual built space I'll be
showing this some of the key collapse
you can see here are the level 1 main
thoroughfare then we can see my mouse is
pointing this is where most of the
streetscape is absorbed I'll show you
through plan later level 4 which is
where the streets the the pedestrians
are dispersed into different programs
that are level on level 4 and of course
the famous Tree of Life which forms the
central of vertical peculiar I guess you
could call it there is a spine
throughout the entire development the
Tree of Life is a multi-level structure
their houses a whole bunch of activities
and the intent for this is that you'll
be a rotating tenant mix and we designed
it so that there's seamless transitions
from levels to half levels who's kind of
like a level there's a 9 level there's
nine kind of arrangement so play is a
framework for retail design retail
experience or actually any experience
one either borrows from play and
make-believe and we kind of have
funneled it down to three main ideas
just for the sake of this presentation
first is kind of the adventure of a
space though the next idea is the the
perception of others and the next one is
a realization of self so aventuras are
if you if all these images are very
foreign to you it is because they are to
most people these are components of the
world of warcraft'
on the left you see here this is a map
of a dungeon it is not as horrible as it
seems just going to kill monsters all
right in the middle here is a place
called Mecca gone which is a place for
the mecca gnomes which are erased in the
wala walk off
this very nerdy you just--just--just
buried me here innkeepers a place where
your rest and this spider-woman is
called yozma she is the end boss for one
of the dungeons she is very difficult to
kill about very fun to defeat but what
we see in the curation of any game is
that or any play situation for the
matter is that they're very common
elements an opportunity for exploration
I think yan has shown that in his museum
talk space for events spaces for rest or
rhythm changes and tangible kind of
kinesthetic appeals to them material and
aesthetic changes so let's talk about a
venture in foo now we try to implement
this two or three main devices it's not
exhaustive but kind of the three main
large ideas so the first one is
variations in movements the next one is
the creation of a dynamic streetscape
and the last one causes the use of
materiality and texture so a variations
and movements as I mentioned before
level 1 and level 4 have been considered
our kind of two thoroughfares
and this was all tied together by a
vertical spine we always found interest
in the circulation to and from the the
first and foremost via Tree of Life or
you could also access this through you
know the escalator networks and the
layers but we did one this counterpoint
between the verticality of this Tree of
Life and the surrounding horizontal
movement that you would have through the
atrium we also this is you know the
design team and the project team also
saw this as you know an interesting play
where it is no longer a situation where
a mall has a giant agent running through
but you could almost kind of suspend
yourself through the centroid room and
move around and that to us was very
important as a creation of an
adventurous space for retail the second
idea is how we transition from outdoor
to Indore
so as part of you know enlivening the
civic district and creating almost like
a mini oasis in the area there are green
pockets there are key parts of this
development the first one of course
being a communal garden I'll show you
some photos Victor there's an urban
rooftop farm a futsal court a garden
staircase and all these can kind of be
accessed from common circulations
leading to the mall either a common
Junction or the engines
Hill Street and Morris Road these are
all semi open space semi open social
spaces semi-shaded with the objective of
forming an oasis in the city and what's
important also is they all of this does
to the surrounding urban scape so as
part of your journey through the phone
and development we we have made an
effort to weave indoor and outdoor
weaving of commercial spaces into
circulation as well as you know we quite
like the idea of people crawling on the
facade so that s why the Garden stairs
is that right smack on the external
green wall for people to walk up it is a
bit of a precarious experience if you
have Otago but actually it is one of the
best views of the city and what was
important to this is that we brought
people outside the mall I know it's a
bit of a counterpoint a bit of a irony
in singapore ways it's hot and people
like to stay indoors but you know the
change of temperature a bit of change of
the sights and smells in the oven garden
actually there's a garden stores
actually quite fragrant at certain
points of the day so we want the this
variation as opposed to the typical
homogenous offering that you know more
my own moment give you any part or any
other place in the world the next kind
of idea that we wanted to bring in was a
dynamic streetscape if you went from the
development you realised that
surrounding the area we've pulled the
paver development design into level one
so as you move into level one you know
we can't try to create a seamless
experience of moving from the
surrounding pedestrianised area into the
retail space and this is coupled with a
city living room that was designed at
the entrance of Coleman so the client
actually made a sacrifice and leasable
area in order to create this social
space high volume and as I mentioned
that I'll show you later we also kind of
tried to you know maybe push the
boundary of design a little bit
especially with regards to user
interfacing this is our well recycling
into phenom oh really was tapping into
the walking's like cycling plan there
was planned into the Civic district we
were kind of looking at this idea of
perhaps changing the velocity of which
people experience them all and this was
a solution so not only is there a path
running through the development that's
poor there
away from the walking cycling plan but
we also have a bike hub located at the
south of the development so the idea as
you can see in the center photo is that
you could come in to work especially we
worked in the upper floors pack your
backpack your bike service it a little
bit shower and then go to work and then
you know bring your bike out after a
day's work so this really is an
interesting dynamic they were looking at
because you know malls are primarily
explored through on foot so we thought
you know perhaps this could be an
exciting way of bringing people into the
mall even at the non more hours the next
idea that we brought into Funan really
is a variation of materiality and
texture I think if anybody ran through
Funan you will see like the common way
of describing it is green gray wooden
metal that's that's really it we adopted
an industrial chic a color palette and
there's of course a variation between
soft and warm hard and cold so some of
the key design colors you can see here
are of course the facade which has a
dichroic paint and is deliberately been
faceted so that as you walk past you
know under the thing about sun lights
you would see a variation in color and
we kind of wanted to also vo we a bit
more from the traditional polished I
guess you could say aesthetic but most
Singapore and buildings have so we did
kind of embrace the grittiness a little
bit almost like a manufactured patina so
in the urban gardens especially on level
7 and level 4 we do have the use of
factories concrete that is meant to
weather and create a little bit of
character when you know after some use
with the plants growing on it and we
didn't want to create this a bit of
wilderness in development and that to us
was an important thing so the you know
these variations between the hard and
soft the places they're air-conditioned
and non-air-conditioned was an important
part of creating the sense of adventure
for 4/9 so that's the first point just
see these are some more examples of our
using material using a dark steel for
the cheer of life as a counterpoint to
the lighter steel of the HM so that the
tree of life becomes more of an
contrasting object so the next one is I
don't know if you guys have heard this
phrase L of G it's the common phrase
used in MMORPGs or massive multiplayer
online RPG's essentially it builds on
this culture
play has to be social there are many
events created in these games for people
to come together it is always integrated
with the environment and what's
important is vistas to other activities
so if you look the left here this is a
city called Orgrimmar it is the Horde
Bay City okay essentially is where
everybody comes together to do
administration okay so if you were to
wander around Orgrimmar you would see
people banking or leatherworking or
trading or auctioning over here is a
raid called rossion where players can
band together to kill a giant dragon
because you know you must always kill
the dragon in role-playing games it's
actually the whole point of this is that
communal activity in play is very
important and which brings us to our
next point the sense of others in Hoonah
we tried to curate this through a series
of nodes and rest points and also
something that I think many architects
struggle with which is vistas and cross
paths and I hope we execute that this
pretty pretty satisfactorily in
designing of this development the use of
lipeh was a common phrase between the
younger architects essentially what we
wanted to do was create the create
spaces for you to just do nothing
these are surgical insertions into the
circulation of the development and we
integrate these spaces so that there's
opportunity for events as well and just
to note that in the development of
Fernan our clients the capital line were
right there with us in this madness so
there was a deliberate sacrifice of less
leasable area in the creation of these
epic spaces so just a few call-outs are
level 7 there's a whole bunch of
greenery with hammocks and all that for
you to sit down relax a lot of photo
moments so the influences really enjoy
that we do have a pool facing Hill
Street there's of course the grand
staircase which I think many people have
have experienced themselves on the right
side some key rest areas as well you
have what we call the husband stairs so
we've integrated into the Tree of Life
which is essentially our bleachers for
people to sit as well as overlook points
so you kind of get a whole view of the
mall through sitting on these spaces and
of course to appeal to the Singaporean
user you know because our Maslow's
hierarchy of needs has changed there are
places for you to charge your
digital devices as well as access to
Wi-Fi so these are things that we
thought would be important it is now no
longer just going to place the shop
in fact finding a place to sit down
maybe experience and your product you
bought you know enjoy unboxing it would
be important in a retail experience so
these examples are people just using the
space more this is the the roof garden
as well as this is one of the coveted
spots of course during national day and
the New Year's Eve parade it is B prime
watchin spot for your fireworks the next
idea is seeing others and this is done
to a curation of just doesn't cross
paths I don't know if any you guys have
explored Singapore during the circuit
breaker and been into the malls if you
can it is rather creepy to see you know
a large architecture with very few
people around so in the retail space we
did try to create a sense of organic
forms where people could see each other
the hustle and bustle the mall needs to
be captured in the retail design and
that was something that we tried to do
so if you went to the development Hunan
you will find that there many organic
forms or geometric forms that cross and
overlap both on the vertical and
horizontal plane and these add to you
know the energy of a retail experience
so just this photo kind of sums it up
pretty much you know as you climb the
wall in your Lululemon right people will
be able to see you climbing up the same
way you would be able to look down and
decide on where you want to eat after
your climbing session so these kind you
know of these stars into other
activities it's important as part of the
social experience of any video
development that's what we try to imbue
in the end of the project so next really
is a sense of self the first few terms
might be very foreign to you but the
monk is a class in the world of
warcraft' a panda is a race that I play
because they're they adorable alchemists
and holistic professions and the Horde
is a faction that I'm part of the sense
of self in play is very important in
every play scape there's always an
avatar or in the world walk off you call
this a tune even when you play
make-believe with your friends you can
you kind of either inhibit the world the
villain or the hero right these are very
basic childhood ideas customization and
identity is important and also to create
a diversity in texture and experience so
the different races look very very
different
I'm a differently and also this idea of
tribes my people and your people some
people have really so entrenched
themselves in the world of warcraft that
they've tattooed you know the whole egg
signal on their body that's there's
mixed of all stuff man so essentially
these ideas important the the
realization of self and in Hoonah we
created these passion clusters six kind
of ideas or six people to be catered to
the the people who are into fitness a
bit of fashion that the game is the
techie is the cross people and the ones
who love to eat which are pretty much
every Singaporean and the idea with this
is that we barely spaces that designed
for purposely to create to to cater to
these people they are integrated in the
Tree of Life
but one of the key spaces actually is
level 4 I've mentioned before where you
have the garden stairs of course brings
you to the roof but we also have
deliberate design for proper spaces so
if the entrance to go to village cinema
you have also the entrance to wall rise
theater so the Waris theater was
designed by Jacques and choco blue and
is the first thrust stage boring from
ancient expression experience like the
Globe Theater formats in Singapore you
also have the service Residence Life by
Oscar which is designed by farm so this
was a collect collaborative experience
especially for these specialized spaces
for these different interest groups so
not a kind of shared a little bit about
Funan you can see that these are the
base concepts of play right there's a
always an initial spark which are the
three ideas of adventurers itself world
warcraft or any other video game for
that matter has developed on this right
by using technology and adjusting to
suit new users taste and expectations
and of course lowering barriers to entry
so i play with a whole group hundred
people from the Philippines the the US
Australia and it's been a joy because
this international community is at
layers to the game and now that as we
kind of move into the future so we you
know covet and make the what the future
of the biome is going to be like we can
just look at maybe two ideas one is this
idea of communal yet bespoke and the
next idea is augmentation so communal we
have a spoke hashtag tribe hashtag
architecture there have
is kind of the symbol of the anybody who
is living the 2020s yeah I think we all
agree without that and just as a segue
when we when foo Nam was about to be
launched so sweet was designed by lekha
like architects and this was kind of a
distillation of the some of the key
concepts of Hunan and this idea was her
windows out and in into the dwell been
just so people get a peek of the Funan
of the future
it was meant for tenants but also one of
the key things was the production was
the curation of workshops which came in
the form of many many interesting things
calligraphy leather working
personalization of ideas and this kind
of all fits within the hashtag narrative
because the hashtag right kind of
establishes a form of community it is
borrowed from all coding language it
establishes a firm community while at
the same time allowing for individual
expression and input so if you searched
through 9sg hashtag you would find one
hundred twenty twenty twelve thousand
posts sorry on it and essentially there
are photos that people have taken of
them all from different angles a bit of
self-expression by contributing to the
overall body of Hunan photos so a
question really then is can this we push
further can can it not just be limited
to photos or videos by the architecture
and space itself are boring from some of
our contemporaries work the aquifers per
billion
20:18 bike right studio architecture was
it was a really interesting study and
this users could touch and play with the
buildings as if it was a toy you know
okay so users could touch the building
and paint with little swatches that they
have just to so the building was itself
a play space we try to do this with
women where users click through motion
sensors do you know a date that's the
facade a little bit and this was kind of
a little bit of play on this idea of the
building editorial the next last point
really is orientation so since for for
any young person you would know that
augmentation of a play space is
important and that's why Pokemon goal
was
that's all right when the Pokemon wall
was layered on to the modern world it
became a new world altogether and
perhaps this is the future of higher
architecture is going to move where not
only would you or men existing spaces
but you've also design spaces to be
virtually oriented we saw this as a very
exciting idea in su T DS virtual studio
where students designed two spaces the
physical environment and the virtual
environment and perhaps in the future of
retail experience design you will see
this you know moving forward so all this
the end of my talk sorry for
overshooting a little bit I hope the
points were interesting thank you and go
have an adventure
thank you very much to shipping and that
was that was very interesting we've got
a number of questions coming in please
continue to send in your questions as we
go along we will now be going over to
Leonard of our SP and he will be sorry
of Rd Ramos studio dries at all and he
will be talking about the squirrel in
you thank you hello and thank you for
inviting me
oh now share my video please let me know
when you see
is it visible we see it thank you all
right thank you so I'm here to talk
about playing in the park I've titled my
talk today the squirrel in you because
you know in everybody that's really a
kid in you and for all of us we are
always looking for spaces where we can
relax let our head hair down right and
have some fun
but our cities are being densify right
they are very little spaces for nature
most of the so-called play spaces are
programmed right and predictable so you
know we need to envision how we can make
green spaces more useful and spaces for
people to play to relax right and and to
relationship so when we were first
invited for this competition researching
the background of this really found that
is actually a swamp previously so we
felt that as an opportunity right to
link our proposal to the natural
heritage right and provide us with a
canvas to showcase some of the natural
wonders as well as spaces for humans and
the community to relate to nature so one
of the first things was we looked at a
swamp you know it was what was
previously dead the problem is a swamp
is a pretty intimidating environment
right you have got all these dense trees
of dense undergrowth and spiky trunks
and and and partially flooded drum so we
thought that the first thing we should
do is maybe different Monday's elements
the basic elements of this swamp area
represented in a more legible legible
manner showcasing those specific
elements right there is that highlights
to you what
special character of a strong winds and
also at the same time creating a habitat
right that will encourage boundless
would be right to come and propagate the
site awry and and provide a points of
interest
this and you see that there will be a
lot of images in this presentation
that's been taken for an Instagram right
this was opposed by some of the uses
they open right well you know use
commonly hornbills there but we're not
just providing spaces for problems and
attracting we are actually creating
environments right environments where
you can get mercy
across it
[Music]
time is a pellet for you to imagine
playing with so one of the brief was to
create in a playground adventure
playground with in this first part right
and we were a lot at the space of -
Hector's happens to be one of the
largest adventure playground simple and
we thought that he'd make sense for us
right to contextualize display elements
relating to what was there previously
right and also make it educational in
its approach so we're looking to move an
explorer animal right - nice and do any
more and so this was some of the
considerations we came up with when we
were exploring in this design there was
the natural habitats of the ecosystems
and there was the educational aspects
right and we wanted to link it to the
movements associate that with these
different animals like flying like the
grey heron right did lie the otter snake
charmer the squirrel and we created a
habitat right that is in the forest
streams running to showcase is affinity
and school and close relationship nature
so the green is actually one of the
photos taken on seven the nest and we
when we created the nest like design we
were inspired by the shape of the
heroness have an in-flight right flying
from tree to tree poaching on trees or
something we wanted to reflect you know
apply elements and and you showed me
these few conceptual sketches when you
wanted to create the Heron mess as an
anchor and then allow
to move from the nest using for example
these sliding cable ways right down
towards the nest and they can then climb
up the Nansen and across evil walkways
so this mimics the flag of the herons
right friend similarly for this little
snake rental racers a common snake is
found around the area right we want to
create an element is not just totally
off the shelf right
not from on the shelf but something is
off the shelf custom-made right so we
create this element and limits the tree
structure right but also included slides
and this tree structure would overtime
be covered by the same the experience
[Music]
by the same time learning about how and
school move through systems so all these
are highlights the program very highly
program nature is a children's program
next I like to display is the water so
this is situated next to the Joomla and
we wanted to really relate to what end
users appreciate right thinking about
how educational right thinking about
tidal pools about source of a ripple
ponds about currents and channels right
and how we can showcasing this but
making a real where kids can predict
themselves they can decide how they want
to engage with this play future he
didn't want it to be highly intensive
highly program programmatic right and
and how the play was decided for
children we wanted the children to be
safe how do you wanna engage with this
play element right but we provided
background in nature and we didn't the
landscape and so this is a typical
superior
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's get this entire part in can be a
canvas for play right
I mean want people to write their own
stories when the Englishman is canvas
but it is very much dependent on how you
structure the spatial arrangement right
how you create interesting typography so
people will be inspired to engage with
the environment right so we were you see
on the right-hand side of this plane you
were trying to create flat urban area
right in the title area for the grey
herons as feeding grounds for the grey
herons but what happened was there'll be
some solve del P will be removed and we
were thinking instead of removing this
soil why not be use it to create nice
typography cool elements like these oval
shakes right these oval shapes are
actually two months right that we use
them as orientation element right by the
whole element for you to look around is
a Vista right and also for you to play
so and then surrounding this humans sea
of grassland right just spreading out
and and which is an unusual feature in
Singapore because you hardly see them so
this these are the mounts right they can
be 3 4 meters high and 250 meters long
and now we need that whole family
sometimes you know taking this
experience playing around you can see
them playing around you know for long
periods of time just letting your hair
down you know when creating landscapes
actually you know transport your mind
someplace else right allow you to
imagine right and and give you the
freedom to express right if you look at
this picture you you you would not think
that this is right and and we want you
to imagine that sometimes you can be in
a different place right because by
bringing you the giving you is my frame
of mind you sometimes engage in
activities that you do not naturally and
in other public spaces so this lady you
know she speaks different sports and she
does her yoga poses right can you
imagine her doing this in or sure oh
it's hard to imagine that right but
within this park setting as this canvas
you can inspire people to let their hair
down and do something like this
similarly we see the landscape as a
props for the Clery on life so this this
is just a collection of oxygen we have
to take down some trees that were not
healthy or in a wrong position and we
decided why not we clean installation
there's also an insect hotel right but
you know but the living is almost like a
prop without actors right and we let the
visitors decided what they want to do
with this right it is beautiful and you
can even my room free so you know one of
these
I think mentioning alphas answer right
expressing her true self really enjoy
myself
we want them to be able to look at the
landscape much more than a part right as
as a place where they can go beyond the
mundane normal life right and to allow
their minds to expand so this is a
recycle tree we call this a recycle tree
we go we build this from recycled
materials collected on-site and you know
there are many ways we wanted to send a
signal right that you know about men's
part in in an ecosystem but allowing
visitors to interpret as they may so we
did in this case another image from
Instagram and this lady she's making a
statement a normative statement she's
got is a gas mask right and obviously
she's and she's paid anticipations
probably indicating that they're you
know means damaging influence and this
lady she's living her dreams right she's
playing a role in cosplay and she feels
that this recycle this recycled remake
of rebus they'd be collected on-site
right is an appropriate prop for a rope
rope claim and she's engaged in and then
is really about building memories
memories for the future right happy
memories have been a strengthen
community relationship right and build
societies and I like to any of this like
because this is one day one of our staff
was there and he took this picture about
this father asking the son to me
right and obviously this is you know the
son do not want to me right because he's
so engaged the place he wants to keep
staying if then thank you for attention
thank you very much Leonard
that was a very interesting presentation
and we are now going to
hearing from our last speaker our very
last speakers or speakers rather Italian
Austria Renata and Florian heinzelmann
of Shou they will be talking about five
P private partnership play places quite
a tongue twister so I will hand you over
now to shell thank you hello everybody
and welcome to indeed our tongue twister
lecture so every kid likes these tongue
twisters so public-private partnership
play places so I exercised it a little
bit so you can also try it for yourself
if you manage yes we're both from
Indonesia or we're practicing in
Indonesia and we're going to show you
four of our projects or realized
projects which are falling into these
play places so public-private it's maybe
a little bit different to Singapore
because I mean we work a lot of ways
with the cities and municipalities but a
lot of our projects are happening the
private sponsorship sees our money
especially in the case of the micro
libraries and places is a sort of a
architectural notion which relates
itself to all of an icon team 10 sort of
opposing the modernist rationalist idea
of space and time into place in
occasions always really like designing
for people and you know how to make that
happen
is very important for us ok one of our
heroes or one of our inspiration is a
constant noon house and what you see
here is his artwork new Babylon and he
was working on this for 20 years of his
life and this is exhibited in The Hague
and he made several paintings collages
videos and models and basically he's
advocating a sort of worldwide City for
the future of the homo Luden's the
playful person so he elevates the people
from the ground towards a space of
self-expression and search and and play
so in a way this inspired also a lot of
other architects for instance and we
already be an OMA and but you know what
is important there is this verticality
aspects the climbing the leaving the
grounds the different vantage points and
this sword is already a lot the previous
lectures that is very important to be
able to you know not only mentally but
also physically change your perspective
and have this upside down you so this is
also very important for for for some of
our projects so also the engagement of
several senses and of course learning
through playing and now we will show you
the first of our projects that will be
done by Dianna so hi everyone so we
would like to tell you a story about a
project that is very dear to us that is
the project that brought us to bundle so
read one coming in 2014
asked us to design from Rotterdam
a place where it is under the passivity
highway and in the past this project
this dislocation under the passivity
bridge which is a highway in the city of
Van dome was said to be haunted so it's
not only empty or deserted or dirty but
also nobody dared to come so together
with a series of other public spaces
underneath the bridge Taman field was
envisioned and it is making use of the
topography and as well as the initiating
from the from the from the highway and
since it was we we meant that it could
also be used as a public space as a
place space for kids adults communities
when it's not streaming movies so taman
field means film park and it is meant to
give facility to the to the movie
community there to stream independent
movies so we studied several radiuses so
that people could gather in different
amount of of groups and these circles we
play and try to create a certain kind of
almost terraces like rice
so that there are many ways to choose
how you would like to sit so this is an
aerial view and what what we like about
this project is that it's like wine it
improves throughout time so there is a
we are using this material of is
artificial grass carpet which then the
city extended to cover the whole space
also the mall stairs and we've seen this
being used many times by different
communities around the neighborhood
because I mean Bandung has a lot of
urban villages and they do not have
public space facilities so a lot of kids
come a lot of ebu and a lot of
communities a lot of gatherings happen
and I've seen we've seen their babies
learning to walk for the first time
there so it is being used as an urban
living room and what surfer's surprises
us the most is that the community keeps
it really clean and this is something
very special for internation public
spaces where sense of ownership sense of
belonging is there and garbage
collecting and and taking off shoes
before entering this space was done so
this is something very very special for
us
so yeah going on on now to the to the
next public space project is Alan Alan
to gender also in bundle and so yeah
here we sort of continue our quest and
and employ what we have learned from the
previous project which is a little bit
this verticality and sort of the idea of
the topography and the spatial diversity
it's sort of not only providing
playground features for the kids but
really trying to stimulate people
through the geometry and through the
landscape to climb up and see what's
going on and this is a very very
multifunctional multi programmatic Park
because it not only has features of
sports and sitting and hanging out but
it also encompasses a public art
and we were very much intrigued from our
experiences in the Netherlands and one
of these very famous and very good
examples is the chromium museum
sculpture park in in Arnhem and what is
here here are two examples and one is
the mail by Jean Dubuffet and it's very
a fantastic piece so we have been there
we have been there with our Sun and it
is a installation from as you can read
1974 and it's a glass fiber epoxy
composite so you can climb up and you
you crawl up through a hole and then you
are up on this sort of almost alien
strange landscape you feel like you are
in a surrealist painting somehow so and
this is with the height and with a
different texture that the different
color is very very stimulating because
it gives you a total different
experience it's also like it lets you
experience art by touching it and by
living it and by experiencing so I did
in encompasses or yeah it activates so
much more senses and on the on the right
side you have the pavilion from other
from ixs own specs exhibition and you
know it's also very interesting because
how art is framed also through this
narrowing down of these corridors and
generating these different spaces so it
is also a interesting way of how to
display art and make art engage people
for for the public and this sort of
references or experiences were
influencing events very much for for the
Allan Allan chichén do and here you see
in this diagram that it is partly yeah
art display so we had a curator from the
ITB us women and he's looked for six
local craftsmen and local artists who
did this cultures but we have this main
square which is important for national
gatherings and prayers we have a
pavilion behalf basketball we have a
skatepark we have real allocation of
street vendors busy with these
blacksmith so we incorporated them so it
is really very very layered it's a very
rich and very yeah multi central
experience would be created here and so
we also employ a lot of different
textures grass block then the curtained
steel a little bit rusty because we know
we have to build it in Indonesia and
it's sometimes a little bit tricky so
how can we employ materials which are a
little bit more resilient to a certain
you know skill of craftsmanship but all
these ideas of these different textures
are really employed also to give
different sensual experiences for the
people like the pebbles which the people
use as a reflexology garden to walk over
so here what you see is the outside of
the park is the pavement is a space
which we call because you know for
Singaporeans or for developed countries
this is something standard that you have
a sidewalk and for us in Indonesia is
not so all of a sudden a sidewalk there
there has emerging you know properties
or activities happening because now we
don't have that much sidewalks and not
that wide and not that protected and not
that flat and what I mean with merging
all of a sudden you know all these
bicycle and and small scooter rental
people are popping up and using this
space so this is something really we
have to think about you in Indonesia may
be much more than a sort of regulated
environment of Singapore how to even
cater for the basics for people and then
of course you know we did not plan
actually a playground feature as such
but then people became very very
creative with our benches so they start
to rearrange these benches as tunnels
and so the the furniture becomes a toy
so it's very interesting us for us also
to see how people start to use or use
our designs completely differently and
then we try to learn and try to get back
to that in the next designs then we have
water features for kids to bathe and as
you see we have sort of the program
versus the generic space or the big
Plaza is used by school kids or snake
shows and emerging activities again you
know we have
this dry garden where we thought like
the elderly people will sit there but
instead of sitting there and
contemplating it is you know a
reflexology garden people walk over it
and the kids use it to not play as
almost like in a sandbox yeah I mean
this was about the other knowledge
agenda and now we go to away from the
landscape projects micro library
projects italiana will explain about
that again thank you Florian so micro
library projects is the project that we
initiate so architects can play too
so not only the users so that we at the
office could also play and it has a
mission a mission of Education and
breeding and we try to use architecture
design to lure people into the building
give some candies such as play spaces
which we're about to show and hopefully
some of them will read that's these are
five of our built micro libraries here
and we have a lot more in the planning
so we would like to take YouTube and
doom again that to the micro library
Hanging Gardens and this is really
important that a private sector also
take part in the development of play
spaces in public facilities because
government alone can't do much to be
very honest and at this in this occasion
we are donated by manila water it's a
company water company from Philippine
and there are a lot of supports from
either and internation that is for our
foundation as well so micro library
hanging garden is basically a vertical
stack garden where we're playing with
with different levels and as well as the
the space that we have in this public
plaza is small and we'd like to multiply
space up so that we only take a small
footprint yet the experience is
maximized so there is a playground
lookout point productive garden working
together with the local community and
then the library is at the bottom of the
building so this is the rooftop farming
when we had the community gardening
together with the youth center and with
the people around
miss school and there is a school nearby
so we think that learning is also
playing I mean planting planting herbs
and and and fruits that's also some
something that that is a play with
nature I think so there is a slide
specially made to give to give some
something exciting for the kids to come
and the slide is next to this to the
library space we're so weak we hope
after taking all right in the slides
they could come into the library and
read some books
now finally we go to our recently
finished micro library Park IO in
Semarang is also a privately funded
project by Kodama is that a foundation
and it will be donated to the city of
Samara and so you see this may be popped
up on your screen a while ago it was a
lot of published so this is a timber
construction and you see we also applied
here again with a typology of house of
still so we have the library space
upstairs and we have underneath a sort
of semi outdoor space very people can
utilize the sitting stairs for watching
movie we have a swing and we have a net
so again sort of the idea of luring
people in or kids in via play features
but then giving them also some spatial
components like communication that they
can look up into the net and see what's
going on in the library sort of to bring
the people up so what we try to do to
achieve this is sort of a well-rounded
experience for yeah everybody and couple
more slides you see how it is the when
you lie in there and you know the kids
are starting to talk with each other and
say pointing upwards and they come up
and or come down and you know back and
forth so this sort of stimulation
through activity possibilities is very
important in
projects and you see here yes that's the
interior yeah naturally lit nice
detailing very clean and very well
executed so yeah this is our last
project very happy with it unfortunately
it's not open yet
thanks to or due to comic 19 but we hope
we will be able to open it soon and we
didn't really really really active yeah
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much architects that was a
fantastic presentation and we've now
come to the end of our talks but we have
a number of questions that have been
coming in and I also have some questions
of my own I think what I noticed from
all the presentations is the the value
of tactility in play and the use of of
different sensual experiences smell
touch a number of different experiences
and I think there's a big contrast
between this form of play and a form of
play that just involves the screen so
it's quite interesting to see all that I
have a few questions for the panelists
the first question I have for Yong is
actually to do with your inspiration for
the for your play and Museum and I know
that you worked with Lee wen but I also
wanted to know a bit more about if you
were inspired from your own childhood
from your own memories your own
experiences or did you indeed consult
your end users by whom I mean children
so if you could give us some insight
about that that would be great okay so
then thanks thanks for the question
thank you for asking this the main
inspiration is to two different things
by my childhood if I can just share a
bit more personal things I come from
Paris suburbs and so people might be
know you come
very nice experience I come from an HTP
state and the community suburbs it is
not right it is not exciting and like in
the 1890s things were happening and so
no access to use my so policy is 30
kilometer away but you don't have access
that much so that's fine for me like
Green has an architect and designer it
was important to design things that are
accessible to the keyboard to everyone
no matter where you're coming from no
matter what is your background that that
you can benefit from it you can enter
free you can enjoy then you can learn it
so that's what does the biggest
inspiration to ensure that the
experience is amazing for everyone to
perhaps say oh I can do the same I can
become an artist I can become a designer
and to contribute to that and the other
source of inspiration definitely is the
artist if I can we can work together but
of course the artwork as well and that
well how we can develop everything by
researching deeply into the life of the
artist into the mindset of the artist
and also the mo the original artwork to
be able to develop installation crafted
from them so these are the two
inspiration from like what I can
fantastic it was very interesting to
hear you talk about how you're not
supposed to draw on walls and I'm not
sure if you can see over here but I did
indeed draw on my wall so I do
appreciate opening up the space to draw
on that's fantastic and I have a
question for you ping and I think we
know the answer but perhaps you can talk
a little bit more about it there was a
question about whether funan was
entirely inspired by the game you talked
about so I think the answer is yes but
but maybe you can give us a little bit
more yeah yeah I think if we are
designed for none entirely around the
world of warcraft' the developers would
have killed us
but to your point I think many of the
other panelists also agree design
concepts and the ideas behind clay can
be applied to any project and bring a
lot of joy to people so yes and no the
base concepts behind any play experience
will always be part of architecture and
that's how we design hunan but we didn't
take direct reference from the world of
warcraft of course yeah I think it's
quite interesting to see also how you
translated your experience of the game
into something much more tactile again
and into into something that includes
sensations of cold and warm all these
are things you can't actually get from
other games such as the one you talked
about I have a third question for
Leonard and the question is how do you
ventilate the snake slide they are small
or they are small holes actually on top
of the cubes all along the troops that
runs down the slide one of the things
that really struck me about your your
proposal or your you're sorry not
proposal it's already built but was the
was the striking path that creates the
edge condition and I was wondering if
you could talk a little bit more about
that you spoke about tidal pools you
said a few things about how that
informed the way you you created your
composition but I find it very
interesting that edge condition did it
come from what was already there it was
a combination of that and other things
yeah so actually one of our objective
was to blur the edges right so that you
know it becomes seamless the surface
becomes seamless most of the time unless
there's a safety issue so you know there
was a question that was related to a
safety and then respect so we try to
make as much of the landscape surface as
possible accessible and playable so the
whole part is literally a Lenski
right where there is some issue of
safety for example when we had Russell
boardwalk right we make sure you comply
with their local safety requirements of
high right even then you know there's
access there's a stairs that bring you
up and down from this areas so you know
because these days we try to be very
free entry so objective is really to
make it as accessible as open as
possible
interesting and I have another question
for Shou this is actually from me and I
was I was very interested to see all the
different textures that you use in your
projects across your projects and I
think in a way they compose the
experience of your projects and I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about your design process and how early
in the process you perhaps begin to look
at materials is it is it a case of
working like a sculptor where you where
you have the materials speak to you and
then come up with a proposal or is it a
lot of back and forth perhaps you could
talk about that a little bit more it
depends a little bit on the project so
for instance the micro library the
timber one it was a complete bottom-up
process because we had the donor the
sponsor and they have a good factory so
we looked it's basically from the
standpoint what can we do with their
wood products the allen allen chichén
doe with a rusty steel that came also
really relatively early in the design
process because there are all these
blacksmiths located around and all these
metal workers and there's some knowledge
about metal and so we thought about okay
could we make something in steel to stay
true to the theme of the location as
well as sort of get the people who are
living there and selling their stuff
maybe participate in those in the
production of the park so that their be
hired as labor from the contractor
because in Indonesia you know
training is not that high so you have a
lot of seasonal workers so and then very
often they just hire people from the
street and since there are no about
metal so we can incorporate them in the
design when we were there it was
actually quite nice that we see people
actually from the neighborhood we were
very proud in silico I have worked on
that you know it's was I was part of it
so yeah there are many many levels of
how to imply employ material into the
design but I would say yes it comes
relatively early in the design process
it's not some form of afterthought it's
that's quite interesting because
everyone works in different ways and
some people come up with form and then
think about material later and I think
it's very important to consider the way
that the workers in the specific context
are going to work I've also had that
experience working in India where I knew
that they would like doing certain
things more than others
so that's very interesting thank you for
that I have had a few other questions
coming in one of them is for Yan and the
person is asking if the experience that
you presented could be brought to the
outside world to increase its visibility
and exposure which is obviously a very
nice idea
yes yes that's a very good question to
ask whether out of those pipe dreams K
playscape from museum standpoint can be
placed outside actually it has been
happening quite quite a lot but more for
very short kind of festival a night
festival or the light to night festival
for the National Gallery so it is
usually over like when we came to
weekends not so much like like design to
inspect him or that his life for
six-month event some installation are
there for almost a year so so that's
that that's a very good idea true to do
that but that means of course dealing
with spaces outside with the other can
we play something there and and also the
when of the issue that we face my
wonderful face for example is that when
you are inside the museum whatever you
design is not a playground so it doesn't
fall under the category of playground so
it doesn't fall under the category of
the regulation for the playground when
you're outside then is no longer museums
is becoming a playground the detect in
you can get some interactivity
a very large installation that kind of
prints game and that was the playground
/ playscape Artscape so so that's doable
but it has to be more sturdy and then
it's really start to become more like
white Leonardo's designing so something
more permanent this whole season when
you go outside the museum the risk is
like okay who can use it what is the
safety and then that which regulation
child comply with that you don't have
that when you're inside okay thank you
actually I'm on that note I have another
question which is to do with working in
an ephemeral way when you when you do
installations and they are ephemeral
they are around permanently do you find
that that's an opportunity for you to
experiment with ideas that you you have
you might end up using later on or do
you feel also a sense of frustration
when you have to take everything down
and it doesn't remain their question
because when you design temporarily the
frustration is certain ability because
what we do we be will be destroyed in a
certain amount of time so it is
recording to make sure that these
installations are sustainable recyclable
of recycled material since it is shorter
therefore you can experiment with much
faster especially when you have during
client I'm the National Gallery and are
really pushing and exploring new things
and so what we do there inspire person
by team too
permanent fixture in commercial
architecture and in school so as we
rondelle we utilize it directly since
I'm a permanent fixture later there is a
frustration that after six months it's
in second and in with already same
question or they're doing with all the
planets that actually demolishing that's
right that you don't necessarily feel so
so don't dust are a bit of conflicting
kind of things that we've always wanted
a to design something new for the people
but at the same time to make sure that
this is a question for Zhu ping and it
is about wayfinding question is that did
you find that designing in this sort of
adventure way you you maybe had a
different had a difficult time balancing
wayfinding with the sense of adventure
and did it become an experience where
people find it difficult to navigate
through the space okay so I yeah that's
a very fair question I think with a
retail experience what is important is
that the shops can be found right so as
architects we are always navigating this
balance between something that's
exciting and something that is easily
readable so in the case of Fernan there
are certain regulations imposed on us by
the developer like a certain offset you
know from the void edge for the shops to
start so in following these parameters
making a few adjustments specially in
the BIM space we were able to make sure
that you know the shops had a moment of
course this is augmented by we had to
have a very solid wayfinding strategy so
the a lot of smart signage errs have
been integrated into the mall you know
using again technology to ensure the
people I think can get to the shops that
they want but yes it's a it's a it's a
line that we always try to walk exciting
architecture is not necessarily the most
tenable
architecture shops need to be regular
shaped you know notes few change levels
and easy to get to which does not make
for the most exciting
space yeah yeah I think it's a fine
balance between those two things and you
know sometimes a mall is about exploring
and other times it's about just going to
that one place and getting out but I
think what I was wondering about also is
that did you observe if you've been back
since it's being inhabited have you
observed a big difference between how
people perhaps play when they're inside
and when they're outside in the outside
spaces that have been made I realized
that while we thought out some of these
views are exciting the the number of
photo moments that we had to design into
the mall actually are very important
with the advent of social media yeah
like some of the photos that have been
taken by visitors to the mall I saw the
most unexpected views but quite
beautiful that we've seen so how people
interact with the building is extremely
different from how we designed a lot of
the rest places are being used a lot
which is a good thing for us but some of
these interesting geometries and how
they come together have been some of the
more attention-grabbing parts of them
all that we did not expect to see yeah
for sure okay the next question is
actually for everybody
many of the designs mentioned are
related to child's play do the panelists
have views on adults play something more
serious because play is often
misunderstood as something unproductive
or non-functional would you like to
start winner so design specific places
for kids to play especially younger ones
man because you know he has to be
contained the parents has to have a side
of them when they play right because
they just have to give them guidance but
the entire part is actually as I said
the canvas for adults in order to enact
their adult 3 right and use for everyone
so it's an program right which is
provide them the backdrop the props and
everything and
and allow them to exercise the
imagination they use it any way they
want right so it really is up to the
adult individual adults and how they
want to use the space right the props
are there you know all the typography is
there you know and and I would say it's
not directed specifically at kids right
it's directed for other questions also
for for all the panelists we don't have
much time so I won't I won't wait for
everyone to answer but one of the
questions has to do with the processes
in making a narrative for your spaces
how do you blend the different
interactions well well let's try to get
that I mean we think that processes has
to do with different context and for us
context informed programs so for for us
programming is very important and
everything else actually comes to
support that programming and so if a
program demands certain materiality or
certain forms and certain statements in
designed and then we do it according to
the program do you want to add something
yeah I mean most of the time it starts
with a certain imagination right so what
could happen there what could people
like and what would be like and I mean
having been in the Netherlands they're a
great play spaces for kids right and we
have a son and you know you roam around
and I think the kid at us is still very
strong so a lot of things are happening
just by imagining what we would like and
how to interact and then you know scale
it up and design it and make it happen
and architects and designers should not
be obedient but should be rebels so it
should let the live let the child inside
live in the projects and when they ask
for commercial spaces suddenly there are
certain kind of like
peih-gee kind of set in the middle of
those possible areas so we can we can
intervene we can make the world a more
playful space in that manner if I can if
you can really react from that it's
because they also this question that
were asked about that the a direct and
and so on when we design is possible for
kids clearly is for kids so the afraid
has to be kept off David hi handsome
and they will always find a new way to
play anything like a tiny little gap and
they will find like an amazing joy I
think themself in song but my father
needs to engage the adaptive and to
trigger something new for them because
they come there the noise for their kids
so the kids will play but it is not who
in or break that kind of shed they have
a random self to basically engage with
their kid with other kids and to
interact with the video space a little
when we placed in sufficiently high so
you need to carry your kid should with
them and so enjoy doing that then it
engages the other in the other self to
play and that and that's quite admitting
food and the narrative in that is very
important because yes there is an art
development but also many the meaning of
all of that for the people and what they
take from them for their own life and
perhaps they can reconstruct that in any
point at any point of time in their own
life to find the play moment and to
really like push phones okay I have one
last question
and this is also for all the panelists
so please answer if you if you would
like to how do you draw the line between
play escapes and playgrounds I already
responded to this question for us we
don't yeah the entire entire surface is
is a player right and and I think you'll
be too restrictive as a designer
right to tell people that you know you
you can only do a playground here and
this is place kid you know I actually
personally I I don't even see a
differentiation in the meanings write a
Playgirl is also play scape is really
really really up to you how you want to
play it right and the place can be a
playground right but maybe we don't
really how do you wanna eat I mean how
we find the space yeah I think that
there's a really good point human beings
will always have a tendency to augment
the world around them we see these as
kids right like a table and chair become
a mountain and a castle your parents
become your mighty steed or like a you
know a giant bear to fight so to I think
we will all agree that the place clip
and play scape and playground are kind
of one in the same as architects we
built the environment but it is for
people to imagine and add their own
layers of meaning to it and that's when
architecture comes alive and gains
meaning and both in the retail space or
in a park or in a school or in a museum
if a playground is sort of more defined
as a sort of a functional separated zone
of a set of play furniture and then of
course we advocate the the play scape
right where it's sort of in to the other
not necessarily a sort of a bordered or
a clearly defined zone because I think
is what is very interesting in a lot of
these examples we have seen here is not
just tied down to a piece of furniture
where you can have a swing or whatever
but that the structure of this space the
landscaping the installation the
three-dimensional elements already sort
of starts to trigger kids to play not
only on this piece of furniture and I
think this is sort of this the sense of
the play scape itself right so that is
not only what the plays there so but how
you structure the whole landscape and
environment and so on and so forth and
the texture and how you trigger people
in kids yeah I think play escapes then
playgrounds are India
beholder so I good answer
like as a user to play didn't go play
wherever you are
yeah I would agree with that well one
final question to wrap up and this one
is it was addressed to young but I'm
going to ask all the panelists again it
has to do with the way interactions
turned out were there any interactions
that you saw that that weren't exactly
the way you intended and perhaps were
either surprised in a good way or a
disappointment perhaps um was not ready
shiping we I think I think what what was
surprising to come out of it is the
number of wedding photos that have been
taken
oh my god it's that case I'm a little
bit afraid of heights construction very
safe but like the number of wedding
couples that have had their photos taken
there has been extremely surprising and
well that's right I'm very happy to see
it but yeah it's been quite quite a joy
to watch yeah for sure
any other takers thing isn't for kids
they of course always do exactly what
God wants you to do I always find the
wrong way of utilizing something and to
make fun with it so so actually does
does the base of play scape like you
envision something because I'm so like
I'm Dimitra 2 meters of course now in
the Asian of the reality is a bit
different so so of course I can pursue
the same thing and the kid who just died
do something radically different and to
and again to take great joy in doing
that so no matter what you designed for
or what you are trying to cater for it
will be totally in
okay well thank you everyone that that
was wonderful to get all your insights
and I we weren't able to answer all the
questions but we tried to address as
many as possible and thank you so much
for for tuning in and we just have a few
things to wrap up with so if you we
would like to thank you for joining us
this evening should you wish to revisit
today's discussion the recording of the
session will be made available and
shared with you by email also we would
love to know what you thought of this
webinar at the end of this zum-zum
session you'll be directed to a link
please click on the link and complete
the short survey and if you look on the
screen you can see that the QR codes are
up there for the survey and if you if
you wish to find out more about programs
that the National Design Center has
lined up for the month of July under the
theme of power clay just scan the QR
code you see on the screen under power
play finally I would like to thank the
speakers for collaborating with us to
make this webinar possible we hope you
found the session meaningful and
enjoyable thank you very much and have a
wonderful evening goodbye